見るのをおやめくださいこのあと吐くときの音が大きめに流れます。
こんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーです
みなさま
吐いたことはありますか？
あの基本的にゲロを吐くときって、こう
いろんなタイミングがあると思うんですよ
こう体調が悪いときとか
食べ物食べれなくなったときとかぁ
お酒の飲み過ぎで気持ち悪くなったとき
乗り物によってこう酔っちゃったときとか
食べ物自体がすごい不味かったり
こう腐ってたりして吐いちゃうときとか
いろんなことがあるんですけども
今回わたくしは
とあるとんでもない動画を手に入れました
☆DO☆U☆ZO☆
それでちょっと気持ち悪いんで全部モザイクかかってるんですけど
ここのとある成人男性がある臭いを嗅ぐと
ご覧ください
あっという間にゲロを吐いてしまうという
（はじめ笑う）
とんでもない現象がおきております
このとある男性の後輩は
後輩：そんなわけないだろう
僕が確かめてやりますよと
彼の後輩も
こうやってその謎の物体の近くによってしまうと
臭いを嗅ぎます
ドゥクククwwww
なんということでしょう
その後輩も
まさに
自然にゲロを吐いてしまうというのです
うわ汚ぇなぁぁぁ見たくねぇなぁぁ
すごいでしょ（渾身のドヤ顔）
二人の男性が臭いを嗅ぐだけでゲロを吐いてしまいました
これを見たとある男性の先輩は
先輩：これはすごいんじゃないか？と
もう一回俺嗅いでみるよ
というわけでもう一度嗅ぎに行きました
うわもうすでに危ないんですけども
まさかそんな二回連続で吐くことはないだろう
と、もう一度そのとある物質の近くへ思って
臭いを嗅ぐと
ああ、危ない
吐きそうですがまだ大丈夫
ところが
ドゥクククｗｗｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
すぅごい量出ましたね
三回連続でゲロを吐くんですよ人が
臭いを嗅ぐだけで
それを聞いた後輩が
後輩：これおかしいぞ
と思いましてｗ
もう一度その臭いを嗅ぎに行きました
さすがにね四回連続はないぞということで
臭いを嗅いでみます
クォォォォォォｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
もはや？
もはや吐いてしまっていますｗ
が
そんなことはねぇぞと
おかしいなこれはということで
もう一度臭いを嗅ぎに行ってみます
はい。
おうわぁぁぁっとこれもまた出ましたｗ
クゥゥゥゥゥｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
いかがだったでしょうか
世の中では色んなゲロを吐くトリガー
というものがあると思うんですけども
今回のトリガーは
です
何の臭いかといいますと
今そこにあるんですけど
友達がね、こうちょっと
スープみたいな、なんか豆乳スープみたいなのを
作ってくれたんですけども
結構頑張って食べたんですけど
量が多くてちょっと残っちゃって
それをちょっと東京とか行ったりして放置してて
気づいたら三日間か四日間ぐらい経ってました
である日、なんか部屋がすごい臭いするなと思って
こう部屋を探索してたら
そのキッチンにあったその豆乳スープみたいなやつが
画面越しじゃ伝わらないでしょう
そこのYoutubeのみんな
ごめんちょっと伝えらないんだけども
ってぐらいの臭いで
もう臭い嗅いだ瞬間リバースしてしまうという
一種のなんか特殊な物質
「ダークマター」にひさしい物質に変化してしまっていたのです
すぐ捨てちゃったんすよ
すぐ袋に密封して捨てちゃったんですけども
思ってしまいました
すごくない？
臭い嗅ぐだけで吐ける物質なんて
もう、そうそう無いと思うんで
今ゴミ袋に入ってるんですけども
今回はそちらの
Youtuberってこう動画で吐くシーンが
よく使われることがあるかもしれないんですけど
これひょっとしたら素晴らしいね
Youtuberグッズが誕生するんじゃないかと
僕は思っているので
ヒューーー
よだれがでた
今回ちょっと頑張ってゴミ袋の中から
伝説の物質をサルベージしようと思います
では行こう!!!!!
！注意！
この先音量に注意してください
3分58秒から吐く音が聞こえます
注意して動画をお楽しみください
では開けていきましょう
ドンキの袋とゴミ袋二重にすることはないでしょ
この中に臭いを嗅ぐと絶対ゲロが出ちゃう物質が入っております
でね今からこの小瓶に移して
私が確保します
でいつでも誰でも人を吐かせることができる
いきます！
☆キラリラリーーーーーーン☆
もう？
アハッハッハッｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
まだだよ、待って
ほらもうなんか
ここら辺のこれですね
☆キラリンチョ☆
マジでヤバイィ
☆キラキラキラキラキラキラ☆
今までにある？こんな臭いの？
ないでしょ？
ダバダァーーーーーダバァダーーーーー
観客：ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
なんか出るもん出ちゃったわ
ここまでくると
ハハハハハｗｗｗ
入ったんじゃない？
OK
サルベージ完了！
よし出来たぞぉぉぉ
無事確保しました！（あれだけ吐いて無事なのか？）
よしぃぃぃぃぃぃ
うわ！うわ！
ゥオオオオオオェェ
見て、見てマジックリンで手洗うｗ
大丈夫、ちゃんと密封されてます
あれしたい、あの
聞き取れませんでした。ごめんなさい🙇
うわあああああああああああああ
はい、というわけで無事（？）何とかサルベージすることができました
これ本当に効果があるのかと思って
ちょっともうちょっといろんな人にちょっと
試してみようと思います
こっからが本番だ
☆キラーーーーーーン☆
はじめ：ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
こぉれはキツイ
やめてよぉ
やめてよぉｗ
いや止まんなかったｗ
シュールストレミングよりさぁ超えてんだよ
俺の経験上これは
☆キィラキラ☆
すごいでしょ！？
ガチでしょ？
☆キラキラ☆
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
大丈夫？
あ”－－－
ヤバい！
ヤバい
これすごいっしょ！？
カメラマン：ｗｗｗｗｗ
☆キーーーーーーーーーーラキッラ☆
アッハハハッｗｗｗｗｗ
☆HO☆RE☆
アッハッハハハハハハｗｗｗｗｗ
もう一回ってｗ
アハハッハハハッハハハッハッハｗｗｗｗｗ
すごいなぁもうｗ
二人とも吐く
はいというわけで
一応後輩全員これ嗅いで吐いてしまったので
危険過ぎるんであんま使わないと思うんですけども
また使う機会があったら使おうと思います
バイバイ！
ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑
ぺー→ぺぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↑ぺー↓
ぺ↗ぺ↓ぺ↓ーーーー↗
ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↗ぺー↓
ぺ→ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺー↗ぺー↑ぺ↓ぺ↓
ぺ→ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺー↓ぺー↑ぺーーーーー↓（ぺーッ↑ペーッ↓ぺー↓ペッ↓）
☆ぺ☆ぺ☆ぺ☆ペン☆
〇完〇